Now, we're going to move away from the distance formula and the Pythagorean
theorem. We'll still use the Pythagorean theorem in this upcoming lesson, but
we'll use it for circles. We're almost to the end of the course, but before we
get to that end, let's talk about the end of a string. Here's a string of
unknown length. Now, I'm not going to tell you what length it is yet. You're
actually going to calculate that yourself, we're going to take this string and
place it on a coordinate grid. Notice that I have one end of the string at the
origin 0, 0. The horizontal distance from the center which is the origin to the
end of the string is 40 centimeters, that's this distance. And the vertical
distance from the origin to the end of the string is 30 centimeters. So,
knowing this horizontal distance, and this vertical distance, what x, y
coordinate can describe the position of the end of this string? Write that
answer here. Once you've done that, I want you to try and figure out the length
of the string. How long is this? Write that answer here.